from first kisses to YouTube makeup
tutorials Wednesday Adams is in many
ways your average American teen but she
hasn't let go of her ghoulish side
either
most people think Wednesday Adams was
born on screen but her debut came long
before the 60s sitcom The Adams Family
like many popular characters she got her
start in a comic strip pinned by
American cartoonist Charles Adams his
woeful tales first appeared in the New
Yorker in 1938 Adams also created work
that wasn't all doom and gloom but like
Edgar Allan Poe that's all that people
seem to remember him for naming his
creepiest characters after himself
certainly didn't help matters it also
didn't help that according to NPR his
idea of a good time consisted of telling
his friends he visited insane asylums
for fun and offered to drive friends
home only to seek out routes that passed
dozens of cemeteries
Wednesday Adams may have existed long
before she appeared on TV but when she
meandered on her comic strip with the
rest of her family she was actually
nameless according to a letter to the
editor posted in the New Yorker Joan
Blake mother in a custody dispute gave
Adams inspiration for Wednesday's name
when Adams voiced his concern about not
having a name for the comic strip
daughter as he went into a TV show Deal
Blake recited the line of an old nursery
rhyme Wednesday Wednesday's child is
full of Woe the cutesy rhyme is a fun
adage meant to determine what a child
will be like depending on the day of the
week they are born funnily enough
Wednesday's middle name is Friday in the
sitcom but despite her morbid Tendencies
she's still pretty loving and giving so
it still tracks it's pretty tricky to
make a six-year-old seem intimidating
without going the full on demonic route
and the 60s Adams Family sitcom faced
that very issue sure a young Lisa Loring
was quite capable of a Fearless glower
but it usually prompted Oz rather than
gasp even her darkest lines don't seem
so menacing out of the mouth of the
adorably braided child
[Music]
can I play autopsy with it
Lauren's Wednesday is kind-hearted and
quick to help her family with any task
that needs doing even something as
mundane as fetching the mail
[Music]
thank you
but while the 60s series slightly muted
her angsty personality from the comics
the 90s films starring Christina Ricci
brought her back to her darker Persona
and aged her up a bit from the
six-year-old she was at the beginning of
the show from then on she and Pugsley
have flip-flopped between being the
older sibling in multiple projects the
fictional Adams Family starred in
everyone wants a piece of Wednesday
Adam's dishonor including none other
than the super sleuth pup Scooby-Doo
Wednesday appears in the episode
Wednesday is missing of the confusingly
titled TV series The New Scooby-Doo
movies the episode only the third in the
series serves as the backdoor pilot to
the 1973 animated Adams Family series
when Morticia and Gomez Adams are
looking for some us time the Scooby gang
are Hoodwinked into playing housekeepers
for the Wayward Adams children after the
Mystery Machine goes missing Wednesday
uncharacteristically wears a pink
version of her usual collared dress
however she's still quick to get 8
Voodoo Booboo while she sticks needles
in a voodoo doll so she definitely
hasn't lost her spooky streak beneath
the smiles and the pink even her parents
are disappointed with her peppy demeanor
for lonely remarking that she's growing
up to be a sweet cheerful young lady the
horrors one of the most hotly debated
aspects of child stars is kissing scenes
that happen too soon for young actors
whether it's in modern films and TV
shows or those of decades past the
concept of children kissing will always
Garner a spirited discussion where
should we draw the line at just 13 years
old Richie had her first on-screen kiss
with future numbers star David krumholtz
who was only two years older The Adams
Family Values scene marked the latter
actors first on-screen kiss as well in a
1993 interview Richie was asked if there
was a big to do made about the kiss she
brushed it off saying no there was no
real big deal about it because I mean
when you think about it there's so much
of that you know in movies and
everything and it's just a movie in a
way it's a little sad that Richie had to
grow up quite so fast and in the
Limelight while she may have told the
interviewer that it was no big deal
krumholtz told BuzzFeed for the film's
20th anniversary that Richie was less
than thrilled with her scene partner's
peach fuzz he noted that made me really
self-conscious
most child stars have done anything
humanly possible to distance themselves
from their most iconic role but
Christina Ricci has other ideas she told
the AV club that The Adams Family films
have had the biggest impact on her
career and life she remains fully aware
of the role that defined her career and
still feels a kinship toward her darker
Alter Ego I just got to do a lot of
weird things that you know normally I
wouldn't get to do Richie told the AV
club I feel very inextricably bound to
Wednesday we'll probably never know just
how much the role-shaped Richie as a
person but she certainly defied the
tragic fate of many child stars so maybe
Wednesday's resilience and strength
played a part in Richie's transition
from a child star to a successful adult
actress she posed this question to the
AV club it's like a chicken or egg
debate did I influence her as a
character or did she as a character
influence my personality in a sobering
follow-up thought Richie noted the way
memory Works in childhood it all blurs
so I don't have a sense of who I was or
what I felt felt like before I was an
actress essentially so in a way she and
Wednesday are permanently intertwined
For Better or For Worse
if you thought young Wednesday Adams is
a mood she has nothing on comedian
Melissa Hunter's adult Wednesday Adams
miniseries we first got a glimpse at
Wednesday's enlightened social views in
Adams Family Values when she ranted
during her Camp's Thanksgiving skit
which glorified the peace the pilgrims
extend to the Native Americans Hunter
took the social commentary 10 steps
further with her Ultra feminist
rendition of adult Wednesday as she
tried to reconcile her gloomy yet woke
disposition amid the superficiality she
faced in La between savagely getting
even with a handful of cat callers and
showing an entitled it girl whose boss
the show's 13 episodes weren't nearly
enough you won a book deal but you can't
afford the ghost writer so now you just
post duck face selfies with your green
juice every morning
sadly according to the Daily Dot the T
and Charles Adams Foundation wasn't as
Charmed as the show's millions of
viewers slapping a lawsuit on the young
comedian and her low budget passion
project after a copyright cease and
desist forced Hunter to take the series
down in 2015. rumors floated around that
the foundation took action due to a
planned MGM animated movie it took years
for the film to happen but that very
well could have been why the foundation
robbed us of a dry witty and woke
Wednesday atoms let's face it we all
have those days where we feel like
channeling our inner angsty Wednesday
atoms luckily for those looking to get
her palette complexion just right MGM
released a YouTube video called
Wednesday's late night makeup tutorial
the video is perfect for anyone whose
real life eye shadows aren't quite dark
enough and don't worry as Wednesday
notes in the video
guaranteed to make you look like you
haven't slept in years the video served
to promote the release of the 2019
animated film The Addams Family
Wednesday takes viewers through her
arsenal of makeup by Brands like
covergirls depressed powder dry and
somber lip chalk and the very exclusive
ashes of her ancestors MGM also produced
a video on how to make Wednesday's
Halloween lemonade and she wasn't the
only Adam's character to get some
animated YouTube Love there were even
some Morticia Gomez and Grandma
tutorials to make your Halloween or a
random Wednesday afternoon extra spooky
a Tim burton-led Adams Family project
has been a long time coming since the
90s to be exact people usually assume
that the Macabre director has helmed at
least one of The Adams Family iterations
that have graced the screen in the past
few decades but sadly that's not the
case according to film stories Burton
even turned down the offer to direct to
the 1991 film with the honor eventually
going to Barry sonenfeld even the 2019
animated film seemed like a burton
project though Greg Tiernan and Conrad
Vernon directed the film as it turns out
the third time's the charm and Burton is
finally lending his dismal expertise to
the dastardly family in a live-action
Netflix series simply titled Wednesday
the series of course focuses on
everyone's favorite angst Queen
Wednesday Adams but unlike her previous
on-screen appearances the ad daughter
will be aged up quite a bit according to
early reports Wednesday's storyline has
a bit of a Nancy Drew Vibe while she
tries to solve a supernatural case from
her parents past with a slight nod to
Edgar Allan Poe she attends Nevermore
Academy
Jenna Ortega is already a scream Queen
but playing Wednesday still proved a
challenge what typically makes Wednesday
a fascinating and Status Quo defying
child is just that she's a child most
people expect young girls to be docile
frilly and innocent when they've barely
reached double digits that stereotype
has faced increasingly widespread
challenges in recent years but it still
hasn't fully gone away and that's
precisely what makes Wednesday a
fascinating character so with an aged up
Wednesday how did Ortega and the
Wednesday writers avoid making her a
run-of-the-mill snarky teen according to
a conversation Ortega had with ew that
was one of the biggest challenges of
taking on the role Ortega explained to
the outlet we've never seen her as a
teenage girl you know it's funny and
sweet and almost Charming to hear this
eight-year-old's obsession with murder
and blood and guts as she gets older
that nasty attitude or those biting
remarks it's almost kind of hard to not
make it sound like every other teenage
girl it's tough to film such a long
series about a sardonic and somewhat
unemotional character but Tim Burton
knows what he's doing Ortega praise to
Burton's attention to detail to ew
saying that has been really incredible
just being such a fan of his work prior
but also getting to know him and
realizing he's the most detail-oriented
director I'll ever work with though
Ortega noted some of the challenges she
had getting into character and keeping
Wednesday fresh Christina Ricci isn't
worried about the younger star's
performance as it turns out Adam's
Family Values won't be the last time
fancy Richie in this kooky World her
role in Wednesday has given her a front
row seat for Ortega's performance and
according to Richie she's living up to
the hype after applauding Tim Burton and
Gwendolyn Christie's work on the show
during a variety interview Ricci deemed
Ortega's performance as Wednesday
incredible Richie told the outlet I saw
some of the Wardrobe photos before I
went to set so I knew what she looked
like in character and I was like it's
such a great modern take on Wednesday
it's so true totally to the heart and
soul of the original but it's also
incredibly modern and it's great if
Richie is down with Ortega his take on
the character fans have gotten all the
approval they need directly from a
generation's favorite on-screen
Wednesday
[Music]